[Music]
you just knew that the media would have
a tough time acknowledging another Trump
triumph
well these killjoys actually found a way
to criticize the president as he greeted
three American hostages released from
North Korea
he has a completing capacity for human
empathy you have three prisoners of the
North Korean slave state and it's about
Donald Trump it's about the ratings how
soon will it be before we see these
images turned around and you know put on
social media by the president of some
kind of you know campaign message Donald
Trump's a former reality show producer
this was a staged production meant for
television meant for the cameras staged
well maybe Holly Jackson is having
amnesia
just four years ago President Obama
staged an elaborate Rose Garden photo op
announcing the release of Army private
Bowe Bergdahl flanked by his parents
that was a nod to the Barons never mind
that Obama traded five terrorists in
Gitmo for Bergdahl who pled guilty in
November to desertion and endangering
his fellow troops so let's discuss the
double standard with Fox News host of
media buzz Howie Kurtz along with Fox
News contributor Leslie Marshall Howie
let's go to you I mean right from the
beginning Obama when he was nominated he
went to that Invesco Field speech in
Denver they brought in this big columns
the Roman columns I didn't David Geffen
was involved in producing the whole
thing I was they believed it was Geffen
I mean he was really good at stage
production here we have Trump at 3:00 in
the morning going to greet the hostages
and everybody's having a meltdown over
it yeah this is such a sad spin when the
president went out there to give a
hero's welcome to these three hostages
to make it about them he didn't put the
spotlight on himself and you know if
some of the media just have to kind of
mock or minimize or denigrate it so what
should be a celebratory moment for the
country let's face it becomes just
another anti Trump story and all he
didn't show enough empathy he didn't
bite his lower lip and feel their pain
Panettiere yeah you know it's same thing
when we went to visit the hurricane
victims this is why people hate the
press it really is Lesley here's a Yahoo
headline after this release of the
hostages Trump cheapens north
in hostage returned with ratings
obsession the president made an offhand
comment about how we're gonna get
ratings history the more that's just
wrong he's just make it a good you know
he's making offhand comment he's not
making about himself getting ratings
this compared to Bill Clinton in 2009
here's some headlines from there in
release of journalists both Clinton's
had key roles August 4th 2009 I think we
have the full screens Bill Clinton and
journalists in emotional return to us
August 5th 2009 when he got prisoners
released from North Korea the double
standard I mean whether you're
Republican or Democrat at least gotta
have a modicum of fairness your comment
well well I have to say and I am a
Democrat who loves to attack the
president every chance I get as you guys
know but this one it should be about
these three men released it should not
be about politics and I have to say I
really didn't think and I know lefties
get mad at me for this I'm just saying
the truth here I didn't think it was
about the president what bothered me was
when he gave credit to kim jonghwan and
that bothered me because these men were
imprisoned they were in the dark they
were not kept allowed to go outside they
were not given proper food or water or
medical attention that was the thing
that bothered me the most in the
comments about the ratings although it
is Trump we do hope Laura we just hoped
day after day that he will become a bit
more presidential and forget the size of
crowds or the roads Lee Leslie there's a
little inconsistency here when President
Trump was on Twitter attacking a little
Rocket Man and all that he was denounced
as crazy as bringing us to the brink of
nuclear war yes he's saying nice things
about Kim now because he's going to meet
him and try to negotiate we'll see what
happens a nuclear disarmament and I
think that you know a lot of things the
President does are controversial
you know with drawing from the around
nuclear deal that's controversial
bringing home American hostages that's
not controversial even some of the media
tried it I think nobody really thinks
that the President believes that Kim
jong-un is a nice guy I mean he doesn't
believe that he says you know Chuck
Schumer our pals are you know maybe he's
okay let's Schumer every now and then
but they're not really pals but this is
part of the art of the deal for Trump I
think and I think he knows that when he
goes to sing of
On June 12th this is going to be a dicey
deal North Korea you know no one really
trusts them we've had a long history of
their going back on their agreements
just ask Madeleine Albright and so I
think he goes in with eyes wide open I
just think it's very very important for
all the Americans were watching the show
tonight to remember how the press treat
Democrats when they have some good news
for the country versus how they treat
this president well we've had multiple
successes and yet the coverage is it's
just not anywhere near balanced
Howie before we let you go do you think
the American people are kind of tuning
out a lot of this though now given that
the numbers are going up for Trump to
new what putting out the bias I mean
they're just treating that press like
they're irrelevant I think that a lot of
people and particularly Trump supporters
but others have concluded that the this
president is never going to get a fair
shake from the media I call it Trump
trauma and we're seeing more evidence of
it thank you both